The trick to getting a politician's autograph, John Rossi tells me, is to try to do it before they go up to speak. If you wait till afterwards, they'll be mobbed. And sure enough, when he spots Pennsylvania's governor waiting to take his turn at a podium, Rossi darts up to him with a special gold pen he brought just for this purpose, and a photo taken in Allentown a couple months ago, of him and the governor. In about a minute, he returns with his prize.
约翰·罗西告诉我，向政客索要签名的秘诀在于在他们上台演讲前行动。如果你等演讲结束后再去，他们会被人群围住。果然，当他看到宾夕法尼亚州州长在讲台旁等待轮次时，罗西拿着一支他特意为此准备的金笔，以及一张几个月前在阿伦敦拍摄的两人合影冲了上去。不到一分钟，他就带着他的战利品回来了。
It says, "To John Rossi with appreciation and friendship, Tom Ridge."
上面写着：“赠予约翰·罗西，怀着感激与友谊，汤姆·里奇。”
Now what are you going to do with this?
那你现在打算怎么处理这个？
Obviously, get it framed. And I've gotten my photo taken with a lot of very well-known politicians. I've already gotten Jack Kemp, Pat Robertson, Pat Buchanan. A whole bunch of them, over time, I've collected pictures of myself with.
当然是把它装裱起来。我和许多大名鼎鼎的政客合过影。随着时间的推移，我已经收集了杰克·肯普、帕特·罗伯逊、帕特·布坎南等一大批人的合影。
John's an accountant from Whitehall, Pennsylvania, and a low-level party functionary, a Republican area captain in charge of 15 polling places, treasurer of various Lehigh Valley Republican committees and campaigns. He calls himself very conservative. He believes, for instance, in a 100% ban on abortions-- no exceptions-- including if a mother's life is in danger.
约翰是来自宾夕法尼亚州怀特霍尔的会计师，也是一名低级别的党务工作者：负责15个投票站的共和党地区负责人，以及利哈伊谷多个共和党委员会和竞选活动的财务主管。他自称是非常保守派。例如，他主张全面禁止堕胎，没有任何例外，即使母亲的生命受到威胁也不例外。
At 38, he is still a proud member of the Young Republicans. Young for Republicans is officially anybody who's under the age of 40, under their rules. And John's experience at this week's Republican Convention was most definitely not what you've been seeing on television all week.
38岁的他依然是“青年共和党人”的一员，且以此为荣。根据规定，青年共和党人指的是所有40岁以下的人。约翰在本周共和党大会上的经历，绝对不是你在电视上看到的那样。
We basically have a lot of activities. For example, SeaWorld, the zoo, Tijuana, plus parties like this that we have throughout the week. We have a nice hotel here with a pool and all kinds of other activities. So we have those things to do.
我们基本上有很多活动。比如去海洋世界、动物园、蒂华纳，还有我们整个星期都在举办的这种派对。这里有一家不错的酒店，带游泳池和各种其他活动。所以我们有很多事情可做。
Basically, it's a vacation?
基本上这就是个假期？
It's a vacation, sure.
当然是个假期。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and ask a number of writers and performers to have at the theme. And this week we bring you a look at the Republican Party and its convention from perspectives you perhaps have not heard in coverage so far.
大家好，我是艾拉·格拉斯，这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》节目。当然，我们每周都会选择一个主题，并邀请一些作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。本周，我们带您从一些您在之前的报道中可能没听过的视角，来审视共和党及其党代会。
Act One, everyday life at the convention. What do those people actually do all day long? Act Two, a Walter-Mondale-voting, gay-rights-supporting, unrepentant liberal signs up as a Republican Party member and ends up a delegate to the convention. Act Three, we have the newest installment of Michael Lewis's campaign diaries. If you have not heard these or read these at all, they are some of the most evocative and original reporting anybody's doing this year on the election. Stay with us.
第一幕，党代会上的日常生活。那些人整天到底在做什么？第二幕，一位投票给沃尔特·蒙代尔、支持同性恋权利、毫不悔改的自由派人士注册成为共和党党员，并最终成为了党代会代表。第三幕，我们将播出迈克尔·刘易斯竞选日记的最新篇章。如果您还没有听过或读过这些内容，它们是今年关于选举最生动、最原创的报道之一。请继续收听。
Act One, Normal Life in an Abnormal Setting. Chances are that if you've paid even a slight amount of attention to what's happened at this convention, you've heard how the right wing of the party dominated the drafting of the party platform, but how the party leadership wanted to look more moderate and inclusive for the television cameras. And so we had key speeches during primetime by pro-choice moderates like Colin Powell and Susan Molinari. Well, in addition to all that, the leadership told right-wing advocacy groups, like the National Rifle Association and the right-to-life organizations, that they would not be allowed to set up booths inside the convention hall. So a renegade vice chairman from the California Republican Party named [? Bach ?] [? Pan ?] arranged to have a 70-foot boat docked just outside the convention hall. The hall happens to stand next to a marina. And three times a day, he organized receptions on that boat for different right-wing groups. He stood on the deck and explained.
第一幕，不寻常环境下的正常生活。如果您对这次党代会稍加关注，您可能已经听说右翼势力是如何主导党纲起草的，以及党领导层如何为了电视摄像机而试图展现出更加温和与包容的形象。因此，我们看到了像科林·鲍威尔和苏珊·莫利纳里这样的温和派亲选择权人士在黄金时段发表了关键演讲。此外，领导层还告诉像全国步枪协会和反堕胎组织这样的右翼倡导团体，他们不被允许在会场内设置展位。因此，一位来自加州共和党的叛逆副主席（Bach Pan）安排了一艘70英尺长的船停靠在会场外。会场恰好紧邻码头。他每天三次在那艘船上为不同的右翼团体组织招待会。他站在甲板上解释道。
?] Right now it's the gun owner. In the afternoon, there will be SAFE California, three strikes, you're out initiative. On Wednesday, I'll be hosting the National Right to Life, the California Civil Rights Initiative. Last Saturday, I hosted an event for California educational freedom. That is the school voucher.
现在这里是枪支所有者。下午会有“安全加州”、“三振出局”倡议。周三，我将主持全国生命权组织和加州民权倡议的活动。上周六，我主持了加州教育自由的活动，也就是学券制。
Although the official Republican line this week has been that there is peace between the moderates and conservatives in the party, you can measure the distance between the two camps by the distance between this 70-foot catamaran and the convention floor. They're close enough to see each other, but not completely under the same roof. On the boat, people mill around, eat fresh fruit, network.
尽管本周共和党官方说法是党内温和派与保守派之间一片和谐，但你可以通过这艘70英尺长的双体船与会场大厅之间的距离来衡量两派的差距。他们离得够近，可以看到彼此，但并不完全在同一个屋檐下。船上，人们四处走动，吃着新鲜水果，进行社交活动。
Look at all these people. How are you?
看看这些人。你好吗？
So you head up the Irish Repub--
那么你是负责爱尔兰共和——
Irish for Dole and the Irish American Assembly, yeah.
“多尔的爱尔兰人”和“爱尔兰裔美国人大会”，是的。
Do you have a card or something so we can contact you when we head back to Washington?
你有卡片之类的东西吗？这样我们回华盛顿后可以联系你。
Two women wearing "Viva Dole" buttons take flyers from a guy who's wearing a green "Ask me about the National Assembly of Irish American Republicans" button.
两名戴着“多尔万岁”徽章的女性从一名戴着绿色“问我关于全国爱尔兰裔美国共和党人大会”徽章的男士那里拿了传单。
My father switched to Republican and all of us boys--
我父亲转投共和党，我们所有的男孩——
My father was the national chairman of the Irish Democratic Committee for years. He's dead now and I know he voted for Reagan before he died. It used to be that the Irish-Catholics in particular, but Irish Americans period, were far more Democratic. Now, the most recent poll-- it's 47% of Irish Americans say they're going to vote Democratic. 43% say they're going to vote Republican. So that's--
我父亲曾担任多年爱尔兰民主委员会的全国主席。他现在去世了，我知道他在去世前把票投给了里根。过去，特别是爱尔兰裔天主教徒，以及所有爱尔兰裔美国人，都更倾向于民主党。现在，最新的民调显示，47%的爱尔兰裔美国人说他们会投给民主党，43%说会投给共和党。所以这——
It's a sign of the changes in American politics and the vitality of the Republican Party that many of the people who you meet here at the convention have switched over from the Democratic Party in the last decade or so.
这是美国政治发生变化以及共和党活力的标志，你在党代会上遇到的许多人都是在过去十年左右从民主党转过来的。
Over by the navigation equipment, the head of the Gun Owners of America and a guy from the National Rifle Association give interviews to reporters explaining why they're not supporting the Kemp-Dole ticket and making sweeping statements like--
在导航设备旁边，美国枪支所有者协会的负责人和一名来自全国步枪协会的人员接受记者采访，解释他们为何不支持肯普-多尔组合，并发表了类似这样的宏论——
I know that the ticket right now is going to go down unless they bring gun owners into the fold. Organized gun owners in the country is bigger than the Jewish vote. It's bigger than a lot of other groups that are out there.
我知道如果他们不把枪支所有者拉拢过来，现在的竞选组合就会落败。全国有组织的枪支所有者人数比犹太选民还要多，比外面很多其他群体都要大。
At some point during this soiree, someone introduces me to a congressional candidate named Chuck Wojslaw. He's a retired professor of electronics engineering, running in a mostly Democratic district on the east side of San Jose. Until 10 years ago, he was a Democrat. Now he stands among Republicans in the afternoon sun, wearing a red, white, and blue bicentennial tie. He spent his time at the convention attending seminars run by GOPAC. That's Newt Gingrich's former political action committee. And these seminars are on how to be an effective candidate in the last two months of the campaign-- how to do fund-raising, how to manage your time and your people in the last two months, how to respond to the Democratic Party propaganda about Medicare and Medicaid, how to bridge the gender gap, get through to more women.
在这次社交活动的某个时刻，有人向我介绍了一位名为查克·沃兹劳的国会候选人。他是一位退休的电子工程教授，在一个位于圣何塞东区、以民主党为主的选区参选。直到10年前，他还是个民主党人。现在他站在午后的阳光下，夹在共和党人中间，系着红白蓝三色的建国两百周年纪念领带。他在党代会期间参加了GOPAC举办的研讨会。那是纽特·金里奇的前政治行动委员会。这些研讨会的主题是如何在竞选最后两个月成为一名有效的候选人——如何筹款，如何在最后两个月管理时间和人力，如何应对民主党关于医疗保险和医疗补助的宣传，如何弥合性别差距，赢得更多女性选民的支持。
One of the pieces of advice was that Republicans tend to do very well in terms of talking about strategy and concepts and principles and data. And when you talk to a woman, she is more qualitative rather than quantitative. And she wants to hear things about what you will do or what the party will do or what the platform is that relates to her everyday life. So you have to do it more anecdotal and more related to everybody's lives, which really makes a lot of sense.
其中一条建议是，共和党人在谈论战略、概念、原则和数据方面往往做得很好。但当你与女性交谈时，她们更注重定性而非定量。她想听听你将要做什么、党将要做什么，或者政纲中与她日常生活相关的内容。所以你必须更多地使用轶事，更多地与每个人的生活联系起来，这确实很有道理。
But don't they think that one of the reasons why there's a gender gap isn't because of the way the Republicans talk about the issues, but because on the specific issues, women, as a group, don't tend to agree as often with the Republican positions?
但他们是否认为，性别差距的原因不在于共和党谈论议题的方式，而是因为在具体议题上，作为一个整体的女性，往往并不那么认同共和党的立场？
To some degree. It may be like-- my best guess is a couple, 2% or 3%.
在某种程度上。这可能是——我最好的猜测是2%或3%左右。
Chuck Wojslaw has never run for public office before this. And talking to him, you can tell. He is so much more emotionally present than any normal political candidate who you meet. He looks you in the eye. When you ask him a question, he actually answers the question. And he has none of that robotic, not-quite-human, pod-people affect that many political candidates end up having.
查克·沃兹劳在此之前从未竞选过公职。和他交谈时，你能感觉得到。他比你见过的任何普通政治候选人都更具情感上的真实感。他直视你的眼睛。当你问他问题时，他会切实地回答。他身上没有许多政治候选人最终都会表现出的那种机械的、不太像人的“豆荚人”气质。
I retired a tenured professorship to run for office. So I could have been secure in academia as a tenured professor.
我放弃了终身教授职位来竞选公职。所以我本可以在学术界安稳地做一名终身教授。
Why are you doing this?
你为什么要这么做？
I love my country. I come from a really humble background. And my country has been-- it has given me opportunity that all I had to do was take advantage of it. I'm the son of a coal miner.
我热爱我的国家。我出身非常卑微。我的国家给了我机会，我所要做的只是去把握它。我是矿工的儿子。
Are you somebody who's always wanted to run for office? You've always toyed with it in the back of your mind?
你是一直想竞选公职的人吗？你在心里一直对此有所考虑吗？
No.
没有。
When did the idea come into your head?
你是什么时候产生这个念头的？
Well, I had a family meeting. My daughter and son-- they're grown, college educated, off on their own. My wife and I got together and I says to my kids, looks like I might want to take an early retirement. And so, my daughter says, why don't you run for office? And I says, you've got to be kidding. And I says, do you know what is involved with running for office? The mudslinging and the long hours and whatever. Then, all of a sudden, my daughter came up to me and she says-- and this is what turned my mind-- she says, this is our country. We love it. If not you, who then? If not you, who then?
嗯，我开了一次家庭会议。我的女儿和儿子——他们都长大了，受过大学教育，独立生活了。我和我妻子聚在一起，我对孩子们说，看起来我可能想提前退休。于是，我女儿说，你为什么不竞选公职呢？我说，你们一定是在开玩笑。我说，你们知道竞选公职意味着什么吗？那些抹黑、漫长的工作时间等等。然后，突然间，我女儿走到我面前说——正是这句话改变了我的想法——她说：“这是我们的国家。我们热爱它。如果不是你，那会是谁呢？如果不是你，那会是谁呢？”
And that's when you decided?
就是那时你决定的？
Yeah.
是的。
He's spending $60,000 of his retirement money to do all this. And like many people I met at the convention, what was most striking about Chuck Wojslaw was his idealism. He seemed completely sincere about what he was doing. We talked for a while. And later, as I was climbing off the boat, I passed him as he huddled with another reporter. He was talking into her tape recorder. It wasn't hard to overhear. He was telling the same story about his daughter in the same words and the same heartfelt tone.
他花费了6万美元的退休金来做这一切。像我在党代会上遇到的许多人一样，查克·沃兹劳最令人印象深刻的是他的理想主义。他对自己所做的事情表现得非常真诚。我们谈了一会儿。后来，当我从船上下来时，我经过他身边，他正和另一位记者挤在一起。他对着她的录音机说话。这并不难听到。他用同样的词语和同样真诚的语气讲述着关于他女儿的同一个故事。
You all know that I believe in a woman's right to choose and I strongly support affirmative action. And I was invited--
你们都知道我支持女性的选择权，我也强烈支持平权行动。我被邀请——
Monday night, depending on where you sat in the convention hall or which network you happened to be watching, you could clearly hear a mix of boos and cheers when General Colin Powell made his big plea for inclusiveness in the Republican Party. It is unclear how inclusive the party really is or wants to be. One persistent and widespread rumor all week long was that gay Republicans had asked for a block of hotel rooms, for their organization the Log Cabin Republicans, and that the party told them no hotel rooms seemed to be available in San Diego or in the surrounding counties, and booked them rooms over the border in Tijuana. That is, the only acceptable place for them was actually outside the borders of the United States of America. This turned out to be false. Not true at all. But the party's attitude about including dissenters is so confused that every time it was said, it had the sound of something that actually might be true.
周一晚上，取决于你坐在党代会大厅的哪个位置，或者你碰巧在看哪个频道，你可以清楚地听到科林·鲍威尔将军为共和党的包容性大声疾呼时，人群中混合着嘘声和欢呼声。目前尚不清楚该党到底有多包容，或者想有多包容。整个星期流传着一个持续且广泛的谣言，称同性恋共和党人曾为他们的组织“原木屋共和党人”预订了一批酒店房间，但党组织告诉他们，在圣地亚哥或周边县似乎没有空房，并把他们安排在了边境线外的蒂华纳。也就是说，对他们来说唯一可接受的地方实际上是在美利坚合众国的国境之外。这被证明是错误的。完全不是真的。但该党对于接纳异见者的态度是如此混乱，以至于每次有人提起这个谣言，它听起来都像是真的。
By midweek, everybody knew that inclusion was the word of the week. Everyone was claiming to be inclusive. Even if you were urging people not to yield to others' beliefs, you did it in the language of inclusion. Witness, for example, Pat Buchanan at a Texas delegation breakfast. To give you the setting here, picture him-- here's where he's standing. He's standing in front of a 20-foot-tall cowboy made entirely of red and black and blue balloons.
到了周中，每个人都知道“包容”是本周的关键词。每个人都自称具有包容性。即使你在敦促人们不要屈服于他人的信仰，你也是用包容的语言来表达的。以德克萨斯州代表团早餐会上的帕特·布坎南为例。为了让你了解背景，想象一下他——他站在这里。他站在一个完全由红、黑、蓝三种颜色的气球组成的20英尺高的牛仔前面。
We're being inclusive today, Tom. Let's all be tolerant and inclusive. Now, let me say this. We do want an inclusive party, a broad party. And think back over the last 20 years. When were we at our most broadest and most inclusive? In 1980 and 1984, we stood up and we said, no pale pastels. A party can't be all things to all people. Here's where we stand. Here's what we believe. We are a conservative party. We are strong on defense, strong on life. We will stand up to--
我们今天很包容，汤姆。让我们都宽容和包容吧。现在，让我说这一点。我们确实想要一个包容的政党，一个广泛的政党。回想一下过去20年。我们在什么时候最广泛、最包容？在1980年和1984年，我们站出来说，不要浅粉色调。一个政党不可能对所有人都是一切。这就是我们的立场。这就是我们的信仰。我们是一个保守党。我们在国防上强硬，在生命权上强硬。我们将站出来——
What's it mean to be a Republican, to be a conservative? These questions even extended to the dance floor in San Diego. Early in the week, one of the conservative magazines published, in a special convention issue, an article that questions the kinds of music played at Republican parties. It is, of course, amoral, pop music that does not promote family values, some of it by musicians like the Village People who live a lifestyle the Republican delegates do not approve of.
身为共和党人、身为保守派意味着什么？这些问题甚至延伸到了圣地亚哥的舞池。本周早些时候，其中一本保守派杂志在党代会特刊上发表了一篇文章，质疑共和党派对上播放的音乐类型。当然，这被认为是不道德的流行音乐，不推崇家庭价值观，其中一些是由像“乡村歌手”这样的音乐人创作的，他们的生活方式是共和党代表们所不认可的。
Well, Wednesday night, the Iowa delegation ended up in a bar called Dick's Last Resort. This was late. It's a place with bras strung up over the bar like spoils of war, a big dance floor. And when AC/DC kicked onto the sound system, a sensible-looking delegate named [? Laurie ?] [? Leapholdt, ?] in a sensible skirt, sensible shoes, sensible haircut, wife of a police officer back home, wearing a sticker that said, "Life of the party"-- "life" in big, red letters-- that many of the right-to-life delegates wore. Anyway, she jumped onto the stage and executed what I have to say is the most incredible display of air guitar work I have seen in my life. Literally, people were cheering. She hurled herself to her knees on the power chords, and she just generally rocked out. When I walked up to her afterwards with my tape recorder and asked where she was from, she replied very quickly, France. But then admitted, no, Des Moines.
周三晚上，爱荷华州代表团最终在一家名为“迪克最后的度假村”的酒吧里。这很晚了。这是一个酒吧上挂着文胸作为战争战利品的地方，有一个巨大的舞池。当AC/DC的音乐在音响系统中响起时，一位名叫劳里·利珀尔特、外表看起来很正派的代表，穿着得体的裙子、合适的鞋子、留着利落的发型，家里是警察的妻子，戴着一枚写着“派对灵魂”的贴纸——“灵魂”用红色大字写着——许多反堕胎代表都戴着这个。总之，她跳上舞台，表演了我一生中见过的最不可思议的空气吉他秀。真的，人们在欢呼。她在强力和弦响起时跪倒在地，她彻底摇滚了起来。之后我带着录音机走近她，问她来自哪里，她很快回答道：法国。但随后承认：不，是得梅因。
?] Having a ball. This is just the best. I drove all the way out here in my little red convertible, top down all the way, except for when it rained over the continental divide. It was great. This country is just beautiful and wonderful. And I know all the Republicans here are doing their best to help keep it wonderful and free.
（笑）玩得很开心。这简直太棒了。我开着我的红色小敞篷车一路开到这里，全程敞着顶，除了在大分水岭下雨的时候。这感觉太棒了。这个国家真是美丽而奇妙。我知道这里所有的共和党人都在尽最大努力帮助保持它的美好与自由。
Do you think that this kind of music promotes family values?
你认为这种音乐推崇家庭价值观吗？
Probably not, I guess. I guess I don't get real excited about a lot of it. If I find something too objectionable-- I'm singing along-- I just change the words. I'm morally grounded enough to know, all right, yes, that has a nice beat and I can dance to it, but I don't necessarily believe everything that it might promote. You know?
可能不会吧，我想。我想我不会对很多这种音乐感到兴奋。如果我发现某些内容太令人反感——我也在跟着唱——我就直接改词。我在道德上足够坚定，知道好吧，是的，那有很好的节奏，我可以随之起舞，但我并不一定相信它可能宣扬的一切。你知道吗？
In a sense, this is a nice statement of how many Republicans feel about many issues, morally grounded enough to decide for themselves what they think and not caring what their fellow Republicans think about it, unless there's some reason to care. Coming up, someone tests the inclusiveness of the party in Act Two.
从某种意义上说，这很好地说明了许多共和党人对许多问题的感受——在道德上足够坚定，可以自己做决定，而不关心其他共和党人对此的看法，除非有某种关心的理由。接下来的第二幕，有人测试了这个党的包容性。
Act Two.
第二幕。
Hello, my name is Dan Savage and I am the Republican Party in my neighborhood. I am the Republican Precinct Committee Officer, PCO, for Precinct 1846 in the 43rd District in Seattle, Washington. If you have any questions about the Republican Party, our platform, or any of our candidates, feel free to give me a call.
大家好，我叫丹·萨维奇，我是我社区里的共和党组织。我是华盛顿州西雅图第43选区第1846选区的共和党选区委员会官员（PCO）。如果您对共和党、我们的纲领或我们的任何候选人有任何疑问，请随时给我打电话。
Now I should point out here that Dan Savage is not just a Republican Precinct Committee Officer, he's also a gay sex columnist, a drag queen, and someone who agrees with none of the principles of the Republican Party.
现在我得指出，丹·萨维奇不仅是一位共和党选区委员会官员，他还是同性恋性专栏作家、变装皇后，以及一个完全不认同共和党任何原则的人。
Now you're probably wondering how a commie, pinko, drag-fag, sex advice columnist found a home in the hate-mongering, gay-bashing, neo-fascist Republican Party. Well, let me tell you something, pal-- the Republican Party is a big tent, a huge tent. There were no ideological litmus tests at the Republican Party caucuses or conventions that I attended. I didn't have to produce a voter registration card, or a picture ID even, at my very first caucus-- a measure, I believe, of the respect the Republican Party has for the rights of the individual. I just walked through the door, signed on the dotted line-- Dan Savage certifies that he/she considers himself/herself a Republican-- and that was it. Who knew that going over to the dark side could be so simple?
现在你可能在想，一个共产主义、粉色、变装同性恋、性建议专栏作家是如何在充满仇恨、攻击同性恋、新法西斯主义的共和党中找到归宿的。好吧，让我告诉你一件事，伙计——共和党是一个大帐篷，一个巨大的帐篷。我参加的共和党党团会议或代表大会上没有任何意识形态的纯洁性测试。在我的第一次党团会议上，我甚至不需要出示选民登记卡或带照片的身份证——我认为这说明了共和党对个人权利的尊重。我只是走进门，在虚线上签字——丹·萨维奇证明他/她认为自己是共和党人——就这样。谁能想到加入“黑暗势力”竟如此简单？
OK, here's the story. Back when Pat Buchanan was posting first- and second-place showings in Republican primaries this year, Dan Savage got it into his head that the only way to change a political party that he not only disagreed with but also hated and feared was to sign up and change it from the inside. So he showed up at his local Republican caucus, which in the 43rd is a small group of Republican holdovers in a big gay neighborhood.
好的，故事是这样的。当年帕特·布坎南在今年共和党初选中取得第一和第二名时，丹·萨维奇产生了一个想法：改变一个他不仅不同意，而且憎恨和恐惧的政党的唯一方法就是加入它，并从内部改变它。于是他出现在当地的共和党党团会议上，而在第43选区，这是一群在一个大同性恋社区中的少数共和党保守派。
And at this point, his story took a surprising turn. Once he arrived, he found out that because he was the only person from the little precinct that he lives in-- each caucus is divided up into a lot of little precincts-- because of that, he was automatically made a precinct committee officer and then automatically won a seat at the county Republican convention. Well, he wrote up the experience that he had at the caucus in the most damning partisan tone humanly possible and published it in the paper. But, as he found out, his adventure had barely begun.
就在这时，他的故事出现了惊人的转折。一旦他到达，他发现因为他居住的小选区里只有他一个人——每个党团会议都被划分为许多小选区——正因如此，他自动成为了选区委员会官员，并自动赢得了县共和党代表大会的席位。嗯，他以人类所能做到的最具有破坏性、党派色彩的语气写下了他在党团会议上的经历，并发表在了报纸上。但是，正如他所发现的那样，他的冒险才刚刚开始。
A couple of weeks after I'd traveled over to the dark side, Daniel Mead Smith, chairman of the 43rd Republican Party, wrote me a letter. "I think you'll be surprised that the hate-mongering, gay-bashing, neo-fascist Republican Party does not exist in the 43rd," Smith wrote. "I invite you to come to one of our meetings and see for yourself." So I went to one of Smith's meetings to see for myself, the 43rd District Republican Caucus.
在我加入“黑暗势力”几周后，第43选区共和党主席丹尼尔·米德·史密斯写了一封信给我。“我想你会感到惊讶，那个充满仇恨、攻击同性恋、新法西斯主义的共和党在第43选区并不存在，”史密斯写道，“我邀请你参加我们的会议，亲眼看看。”于是我参加了史密斯的一次会议，看看我自己，即第43选区共和党党团会议。
I arrived at the Montlake Community Center for the 1996 43rd District Republican Caucuses at 8:00 AM. I paid my $5, signed in, grabbed a seat, and waited for the work to begin. We were there to elect delegates to the State Republican Convention coming up Memorial Day weekend and vote on non-binding resolutions. The caucus began with a prayer. We asked God to guide us in selecting delegates. And then we were ready to pledge allegiance to the flag. Only trouble was, no one brought a flag. I thought about suggesting we pledge allegiance to the fag-- hey that's me-- but I didn't want to be disruptive. Someone found some red, white, and blue bunting in the back room, tossed it over an easel, and we pledged allegiance to that. The easel was needed post-pledge. So the red, white, and blue bunting to which we had just pledged our allegiance was tossed on the floor.
我于上午8点到达蒙特莱克社区中心参加1996年第43选区共和党党团会议。我付了5美元，签到，找了个座位，等待工作开始。我们在那里选举参加即将到来的阵亡将士纪念日周末的州共和党代表大会的代表，并就非约束性决议进行投票。党团会议以祈祷开始。我们祈求上帝指引我们在选择代表时做出正确的决定。然后我们准备向国旗宣誓。唯一的麻烦是，没人带旗子。我曾考虑建议我们向“同性恋者”（fag，谐音flag）宣誓——嘿，那就是我——但我不想破坏气氛。有人在后屋找了一些红白蓝相间的彩带，把它扔在一个画架上，我们就向那个宣誓。宣誓后需要用到画架，于是我们刚刚向其宣誓的红白蓝彩带就被扔在了地上。
We had to elect delegates before we could get to the resolutions. I won't bore you with the Robert's Rules of Order stuff or the impossibly convoluted process by which the 80 of us in that cramped, steeple-roofed, fluorescent-lit room elected 17 delegates to the State Republican Convention. Suffice to say, it was crushingly dull. To entertain us while we waited for the ballots to be counted four times, Republican Party activists and candidates gave little speeches. Some of these speeches were pure fantasy. One woman read a prepared speech about the United Nations working in concert with abortionists to take over the country.
在进入决议之前，我们必须选举代表。我不会用罗伯特议事规则或那个拥挤、屋顶呈尖塔状、日光灯照明的房间里80个人选举17名州党代会代表的极其复杂的程序来打扰你们。总之，这真是极其无聊。在我们等待计票四次期间，为了娱乐我们，共和党活动家和候选人发表了一些简短的演讲。其中一些演讲纯属幻想。一位女士读了一篇准备好的演讲，内容是联合国与堕胎者勾结以接管国家。
The other recurring fantasy had to do with us, the 43rd District Republicans, retaking the 43rd for the Republican Party. One man reminisced about the time, not too long ago, when the 43rd was a solidly Republican district. "We can make this district Republican again, just like it was when I joined the party 25 years ago. All we have to do is get out there and doorbell and identify the voters in this district who are sympathetic to our issues."
另一个反复出现的幻想与我们——第43选区共和党人——为共和党夺回第43选区有关。一名男子回忆起不久前第43选区还是一个坚实的共和党选区的时候。“我们可以让这个选区再次成为共和党地盘，就像我25年前加入该党时一样。我们所要做的就是走出去，挨家挨户敲门，找出这个选区内同情我们议题的选民。”
Heart pounding, I stuck my hand in the air. "Have any of you been out of the house or walked down Broadway in the last 25 years?" I asked, standing and looking around at the toughest crowd I've probably ever played. The 43rd District, I pointed out, had gone all gay all of a sudden. So long as the Republican Party was identified with homophobes and anti-gay, bigot activists, the Republican Party could kiss the 43rd District goodbye.
心跳加速，我把手伸向空中。“过去25年里，你们中有人走出家门或走在百老汇大街上吗？”我站起来，环顾四周，看着我可能见过的最强硬的一群人问道。我指出，第43选区突然间全变成了同性恋。只要共和党被认为与恐同者、反同性恋和偏执活动家划等号，共和党就可以告别第43选区了。
When I sat down, a little old lady sitting behind me pointed out that she knew a very nice gay couple in the Republican Party. In other words, she, and by extension the party, was not homophobic. And I was wrong.
当我坐下时，坐在我身后的一位老太太指出，她认识共和党内一对非常好的同性恋伴侣。换句话说，她，并延伸到整个党，不是恐同的。而我错了。
She said to me, "The party isn't against gay people. That's just a false impression you have." Gee, I wonder where I could have picked up that false impression? Maybe from Jesse Helms, Bob Dornan, Bob "$1,000" Dole, anti-gay rights rallies in Iowa during the primaries attended by all the Republican presidential hopefuls-- even moderate Lamar Alexander-- Pat Robertson, Ralph Reed, Newt Gingrich, Linda Smith, Ellen Craswell, Spokane County Coroner Dexter Amend, the Washington State Legislature, state legislatures all across the country, the Christian Coalition.
她对我说：“该党并不反对同性恋者。那只是你有的一个错误印象。”天哪，我想知道我是在哪里产生那个错误印象的？也许是杰西·赫尔姆斯、鲍勃·多南、鲍勃·“1000美元”·多尔、初选期间在爱荷华州举行的、所有共和党总统竞选人——甚至温和派拉马尔·亚历山大——都参加的反同性恋权利集会，帕特·罗伯逊、拉尔夫·里德、纽特·金里奇、琳达·史密斯、艾伦·克拉斯韦尔、斯波坎县验尸官德克斯特·阿曼德、华盛顿州立法机构、全国各地的州立法机构、基督教联盟。
During a break, an attractive middle-aged man approached me. He was a little angry. "I was offended by you forcing me to take responsibility for Jesse Helms." As if the Republican Party isn't responsible for Jesse Helms. One woman wanted to know why she should support gay people since gay people didn't support her when her home was burned down by arsonists. The arsonists weren't gay or anything. But where were gay people when she needed them? Another pointed out that some gays had broken the windows of the Republican Party headquarters, so who's oppressing who?
休息期间，一位有魅力的中年男子走近我。他有点生气。“你强迫我为杰西·赫尔姆斯承担责任，这让我感到被冒犯了。”好像共和党不对杰西·赫尔姆斯负责似的。一位女士想知道，既然当她的家被纵火犯烧毁时同性恋者没有支持她，她为什么要支持同性恋者。纵火犯并不是同性恋什么的。但当她需要他们时，同性恋者在哪里？另一个人指出，一些同性恋者打碎了共和党总部的窗户，所以到底是谁在压迫谁？
Another man took me aside during a break to let me know that the gay bashing within the Republican Party wasn't for real. It was only to get out the vote and motivate the front lines. Well, then, I guess that makes it OK. I'm happy to be vilified and scapegoated and denied my civil rights, so long as it motivates people to go to the polls. Disenfranchisement is a small price to pay to increase voter turnout.
休息期间，另一名男子把我拉到一边，让我知道共和党内的反同性恋攻击不是真的。这只是为了动员选票和激励前线。好吧，那么，我想那让它变得可以接受了。我很乐意被诽谤、被当作替罪羊和被剥夺公民权利，只要这能激励人们去投票。只要能提高选民投票率，被剥夺权利只是一个小小的代价。
To his surprise, at this meeting, Dan Savage talked the caucus into approving a resolution that affirmed the rights of gays and lesbians and rejected elements of the party who would exploit fear and hatred of homosexuals for short-term political gain. He could not wait, after this victory, to get to the county convention. As an official delegate, Dan Savage would be allowed to vote there. He'd be allowed to make amendments. He would really be allowed to play a role. He planned to vote, in the straw polls they have at these things, for the most conservative Republican candidates-- in this case, Pat Buchanan for president. And for the governor of Washington State, he was going to vote for Ellen Craswell, who opposes gun control, and gay rights, and moral decay, and who he loathes.
令他惊讶的是，在这次会议上，丹·萨维奇说服党团会议批准了一项决议，确认了男女同性恋者的权利，并拒绝了党内那些为了短期政治利益而利用对同性恋者的恐惧和仇恨的分子。这次胜利后，他迫不及待地想去县党代会。作为一名正式代表，丹·萨维奇将被允许在那里投票。他将被允许提出修正案。他真的会被允许发挥作用。他计划在这些会议上的非正式投票中，投票给最保守的共和党候选人——在这种情况下，是帕特·布坎南竞选总统。对于华盛顿州州长，他打算投票给艾伦·克拉斯韦尔，她反对枪支管制、同性恋权利和道德败坏，而且他极其厌恶她。
Dan Savage's thinking was that the more extreme the Republican ticket would end up being, the more likely they would lose in the general election, and the more likely that the party would eventually abandon this more conservative wing.
丹·萨维奇的想法是，共和党的竞选组合越极端，他们在普选中就越有可能失败，该党最终放弃这个更保守派别的可能性就越大。
A few weeks later, the big day arrived. The King County Republican Convention, my first major party function-- hats, speeches, amendments. I bounded out of bed at 7:00 AM, and ran to meet my new friend, Steve, at the QFC on Broadway. Steve attended his precinct caucuses way back in March with the intention of getting himself elected a delegate to the county and state Republican conventions. Like me, he joined the Republican Party out of a sincere desire to move the GOP to the center. Kindred spirits, we decided to attend the county convention together.
几周后，大日子到了。金县共和党代表大会，我的第一个大型党内活动——帽子、演讲、修正案。我早上7点从床上跳起来，跑去百老汇的QFC超市见我的新朋友史蒂夫。史蒂夫早在三月就参加了他的 precinct 党团会议，目的是让自己当选为县和州共和党代表大会的代表。像我一样，他出于将共和党推向中间路线的真诚愿望加入了共和党。作为志同道合的人，我们决定一起参加县代表大会。
The doors opened at 7:30 AM. After the crowd settled down, a preacher read an alarming opening invocation which pretty much set the tone for what was to come. "Please forgive our leaders for endorsing perversion. And God, deliver us from spineless compromise." Then we bellowed the Pledge of Allegiance to the flag of the United States of America. I slipped up to the merchandise tables on the second floor where I bought myself a red, white, and blue "Craswell for Governor" hat.
大门在早上7点30分打开。人群平静下来后，一位牧师朗读了一段令人震惊的开幕祈祷词，这基本定下了即将发生的事情的基调。“请原谅我们的领导人支持变态行为。上帝啊，把我们从无脊柱的妥协中解救出来吧。”然后我们大声朗读了对美利坚合众国国旗的效忠誓词。我溜到二楼的商品摊位，给自己买了一顶红白蓝三色的“克拉斯韦尔竞选州长”帽子。
It must have been fate. On my way back down from the merchandise tables, I ran smack dab into Ellen Craswell herself. I said hello, and looking very serious in my little red, white, and blue hat asked, "What are we going to do about the homosexual problem, Miss Craswell? What is the final solution to all this homosexual nonsense?"
一定是缘分。在从商品摊位回来的路上，我正好撞见了艾伦·克拉斯韦尔本人。我打了个招呼，戴着那顶红白蓝小帽子，一脸严肃地问道：“我们打算怎么处理同性恋问题，克拉斯韦尔小姐？对于所有这些同性恋荒唐事，有什么最终解决方案吗？”
"So long as they stay inside, we can let them alone," Ellen Craswell confided in me. "But when they organize and demand special rights, we must oppose them. We can't give special rights to something that is an abomination in the eyes of God."
“只要他们呆在室内，我们可以不去管他们，”艾伦·克拉斯韦尔向我透露，“但当他们组织起来并要求特殊权利时，我们必须反对他们。我们不能把特殊权利给予在上帝眼中是可憎的东西。”
Now, Ellen didn't seem interested in elaborating on just what it is we're supposed to stay inside of-- the closet, our apartments, the priesthood. So I said goodbye, promising to vote for her in the primary. You see, the better Ellen does in the primary, the better the Democratic candidate for governor will do in the fall.
现在，艾伦似乎对详细说明我们应该呆在什么东西的里面不感兴趣——衣橱、公寓、牧师职位。所以我说了再见，并承诺在初选中投她一票。你看，艾伦在初选中表现得越好，民主党州长候选人在秋季的表现就会越好。
I made it back to the convention floor just in time for the opening of debate on the party platform. The King County Republican Platform is a document drawn up by committee that lays out what the King County Republican Party stands for. And here's the beautiful part-- delegates are allowed to propose amendments. Once an amendment is proposed, the amendment's sponsor is allowed to speak, followed by a few people in favor, a few opposed. After that, the sponsor gets another minute or so to address the floor. I was a delegate. I had amendments. And so I would get to address the convention over and over and over again. And as amendments are time-consuming, determined delegates can grind the convention to a halt.
我及时赶回了党代会大厅，正好赶上关于党纲的辩论开始。金县共和党党纲是一份由委员会起草的文件，规定了金县共和党的主张。精彩的部分来了——代表们可以提出修正案。一旦提出修正案，修正案的发起人可以发言，随后是几名赞成者、几名反对者。此后，发起人再有大约一分钟时间向会场致辞。我是代表。我有修正案。所以我可以一次又一次地向代表大会致辞。由于修正案很耗时，坚定的代表们可以使大会陷入停顿。
The first section we were to vote on was the preamble, in which we acknowledged God to be our creator and the family as the foundation of our culture. We embraced free markets, recognized that tax and regulatory burdens are a threat to our freedoms, yadda, yadda, yadda. Before we could vote on the preamble-- and it hadn't occurred to me to amend the preamble-- a delegate proposed that a line be added stating that the party was open to all who accept its basic principles, regardless of race, religion, sex, or national origin.
我们投票的第一部分是序言，我们在序言中承认上帝是我们的创造者，家庭是我们文化的基石。我们拥抱自由市场，认识到税收和监管负担是对我们自由的威胁，等等等等。在我们投票通过序言之前——我还没想到要修改序言——一位代表提议增加一行文字，说明该党向所有接受其基本原则的人开放，不分种族、宗教、性别或国籍。
After debate, the first resolution of the day passed by a distressingly narrow margin. Race, creed, sex, national origin-- something was missing.
经过辩论，当天的第一项决议以微弱的优势通过了。种族、信仰、性别、国籍——还缺了点什么。
Steve approached the microphone and proposed that the just-passed amendment also be amended to include the words "sexual orientation." Well, Steve's amendment was soundly defeated by a voice vote that, though untabulated, sounded to me like 1,589 to 11. Then the liberty section was up for a vote.
史蒂夫走到麦克风前，提议将刚通过的修正案进行修改，加入“性取向”这一词。嗯，史蒂夫的修正案在语音投票中被彻底击败，虽然没有计票，但在我听来像是1589比11。然后是关于自由部分的投票。
I dashed to a microphone wearing my Ellen Craswell hat and proposed this amendment. "As respect for the rights of the individual are the bedrock of Republican values, the King County Republican Party hereby recognizes the fundamental human rights of gay and lesbian American citizens. We reject elements on the fringe of the Republican Party that would exploit fear and hatred of gay and lesbian American citizens for short-term political gain."
我戴着那顶艾伦·克拉斯韦尔的帽子冲向麦克风，提出了这项修正案。“由于尊重个人权利是共和党价值观的基石，金县共和党特此承认男女同性恋美国公民的基本人权。我们拒绝共和党边缘那些为了短期政治利益而利用对男女同性恋美国公民的恐惧和仇恨的分子。”
Through the shouting, I pointed out that we King County Republicans can't have it both ways. We can't say in one breath that we oppose discrimination and with our next breath, support discrimination against gay and lesbian American citizens. So let's vote on it. Do we, the Republicans of King County, recognize the fundamental rights of gay and lesbian American citizens, or do we not? Well, we do not. After some heated debate-- the names I was called-- pervert, sodomite, Democrat-- my amendment was voted down.
在叫喊声中，我指出，我们金县共和党人不能两全其美。我们不能一方面说我们反对歧视，另一方面又支持对男女同性恋美国公民的歧视。所以让我们表决吧。我们，金县的共和党人，是否承认男女同性恋美国公民的基本权利，还是不承认？嗯，我们不承认。经过一番激烈的辩论——我被叫的名字——变态、鸡奸者、民主党——我的修正案被投票否决了。
After my amendment failed, a woman in a Craswell hat approached me. "Why are you wearing that hat?" she briskly inquired.
我的修正案失败后，一位戴着克拉斯韦尔帽子的女士走近我。“你为什么要戴那顶帽子？”她干脆地问。
"Because I'm for Craswell."
“因为我支持克拉斯韦尔。”
"You know where she stands on gay things, don't you?" Having recently had a conversation with Ellen herself, I most certainly did.
“你知道她在同性恋问题上的立场，对吧？”最近和艾伦本人交谈过，我当然知道。
"But I'm not," I smilingly inform my new friend and fellow Craswell supporter, "a single-issue voter."
“但我不是，”我微笑着告诉我的新朋友和克拉斯韦尔支持者，“单议题选民。”
Try to imagine now that you're a homophobic, Republican jerk-off-- which might be a triple redundancy-- at your county convention. You came for the speeches, an anti-Clinton T-shirt for your collection, and a hot dog. This is what you do for fun. Woohoo. But these three guys keep introducing pro-gay-rights amendments, moving to have anti-gay amendments struck, and generally messing with your afternoon.
现在试着想象一下，你是一个恐同的、共和党的混蛋——这可能是一个三重赘述——在你们的县代表大会上。你来是为了听演讲、为你收集的T恤找一件反克林顿的，还有吃个热狗。这就是你觉得好玩的。呜呼。但这三个人一直在提出支持同性恋权利的修正案，动议撤销反同性恋修正案，并且总体上在搞乱你的下午。
You didn't come to the convention to defend your party's homophobia. And you certainly didn't come expecting to listen to gay men giving speeches all day long. Who are these guys? And why is that one wearing a Craswell hat? OK, you're this person. What do you do? You get mad-- very, very mad.
你来代表大会可不是为了捍卫你所在政党的恐同情绪的。你当然也没想到要整天听着同性恋男子发表演讲。这些人是谁？为什么那个人戴着克拉斯韦尔的帽子？好了，你就是这个人。你会怎么做？你会生气——非常、非常生气。
One delegate decided to get even. In what can only be described as a David Lynch moment, a palsied delegate staggered up to the microphone and proposed a change in the rules. No further discussion of homosexuality allowed. His resolution needed a 2/3 majority to pass because it was a rules change, not a simple amendment. And pass it did, to hoots and hollers and cheers.
一位代表决定反击。在一个只能被描述为大卫·林奇式的时刻，一位患有震颤麻痹的代表踉踉跄跄地走到麦克风前，提议修改规则。不再允许讨论同性恋。他的决议需要三分之二的多数票才能通过，因为这是规则修改，而不是简单的修正案。它通过了，伴随着嘘声、欢呼和叫好声。
But we had yet to vote on the education section, which contained a plank about homosexuality. When we got to education, all hell broke loose. Robert's Rules of Order fetishists leapt to their feet insisting that the anti-gay plank in the Education section would have to be struck. If we can't discuss homosexuality, we can't vote on it, for voting is a discussion. Uh-oh, we were talking about homosexuality again. People were booing, shouting. Oh, the humanity.
但我们还没就教育部分投票，其中包含了一项关于同性恋的条款。当我们讨论到教育时，一切都乱套了。罗伯特议事规则的狂热分子跳了起来，坚称教育部分中的反同性恋条款必须删除。如果我们不能讨论同性恋，我们就不能投票，因为投票本身就是一种讨论。哦哦，我们又在谈论同性恋了。人们在起哄、尖叫。噢，人道啊。
The chair, bringing the room to order, calmly ruled that the no-further-discussion resolution applied only to pro-gay discussions. We could discuss homosexuality, he said, but only if we weren't saying anything nice about it. And the convention limped to a close, most of the day having been wasted debating gay rights, gay marriage, what makes people gay, and my hat.
主席维持秩序，冷静地裁定不再讨论的决议仅适用于支持同性恋的讨论。他说我们可以讨论同性恋，但前提是我们不能说关于它的任何好话。代表大会步履蹒跚地结束了，大部分时间都浪费在辩论同性恋权利、同性婚姻、什么造就了同性恋，以及我的帽子上了。
What I learned. Here's what I learned about Republicans that weekend. They don't like homos very much. They certainly don't like having to talk about us. And they certainly like listening to us even less. But they do like beating up on us in their platforms. So King County Republicans, I'll make you a deal. Leave us out of your platform in '98-- the next convention cycle-- and I'll stay away from your convention. But if we're in the platform, I intend to return.
我学到了什么。这就是那个周末我关于共和党学到的东西。他们不太喜欢同性恋者。他们当然不喜欢不得不谈论我们。而且他们更不喜欢听我们说话。但他们确实喜欢在党纲里打击我们。所以金县共和党人，我和你们做个交易。在98年的下一个代表大会周期里，把我们从党纲中删掉，我就远离你们的代表大会。但如果我们要出现在党纲里，我打算回来。
Dan Savage writes a syndicated sex advice column called "Savage Love." He's a writer and editor at a weekly Seattle paper called The Stranger.
丹·萨维奇写了一份联合刊出的性建议专栏，名为“萨维奇之爱”。他是西雅图一家周报《陌生人》的作家和编辑。
Coming up, Michael Lewis and more unusual stories of Republican Party politics. That's in a minute, when our program continues.
接下来，迈克尔·刘易斯和更多不寻常的共和党政治故事。一分钟后，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of writers and stories and storytelling styles. Our program today is about the Republican Convention. Act Three, Campaign Diaries.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都会在节目中选择一个主题，带来各种作家、故事和讲故事的风格。我们今天的节目是关于共和党代表大会的。第三幕，竞选日记。
Throughout this year, we've been bringing you the reportage of Michael Lewis. He's publishing his campaign diaries in The New Republic . And I say this pretty much every time we have him on the show. He's writing about corners of the election process that nobody else is. He just has this eye, also, for the telling, revealing little moment and detail. Regular listeners to our program or regular readers of his know that at some point during this election year, Michael Lewis became mesmerized with a presidential candidate by the name of Morry Taylor. Morry Taylor ran in the Republican primaries. He shows up in this installment you're about to hear. He is outspoken. And he is the founder and CEO of Titan Tire and Wheel. And he goes by the nickname the Grizz.
今年全年，我们一直在为你们带来迈克尔·刘易斯的报道。他正在《新共和》杂志上发表他的竞选日记。我几乎每次他在节目中出现时都会这么说。他正在撰写选举过程中没人关注的角落。他就是有这种眼光，能捕捉到那些传神的、揭示真相的细节。我们节目的常客或他的忠实读者都知道，在今年选举年的某个时刻，迈克尔·刘易斯迷上了一位名叫莫里·泰勒的总统候选人。莫里·泰勒参加了共和党初选。他出现在你们即将听到的这一期节目中。他直言不讳。他是泰坦轮胎与车轮公司的创始人和首席执行官。他用的绰号是“灰熊”。
For these campaign diaries, Michael Lewis not only attended the Republican National Convention, he also flew to Russell, Kansas, Bob Dole's boyhood home.
为了这些竞选日记，迈克尔·刘易斯不仅参加了共和党全国代表大会，他还飞往鲍勃·多尔的童年故乡堪萨斯州的拉塞尔。
August 7-- I don't really expect anyone to answer the door of Bob Dole's house in Russell, Kansas. But I stop by anyway, just to see what might happen. When you travel with Dole, you see the world as it is constructed by the Dole campaign, until you almost forget there is a world outside of it, where people do the unexpected. Indeed, as I reach for the screen door, I half wonder if some SWAT team will leap out of the bushes and haul me back to Bob Dole's campaign plane, Citizenship , for questioning.
8月7日——我并没有真正期望有人会回应鲍勃·多尔在堪萨斯州拉塞尔的家门。但我还是顺道过去，看看会发生什么。当你和多尔一起旅行时，你看到的世界是由多尔竞选团队构建的，直到你几乎忘记了外面还有一个世界，那里的人们会做些意想不到的事。事实上，当我伸手去拉纱门时，我甚至半开玩笑地想，会不会有一支特种部队从灌木丛中跳出来，把我带回鲍勃·多尔的竞选飞机“公民号”上审问。
But Dole is a few days behind me. And the neighborhood remains undisturbed by politics. The only sign that I'm in the right place is the faded pink mat beneath my feet. "Welcome to the home of the Doles," it reads. After a single ring, the front door swings open and an elderly woman steps outside.
但多尔比我晚到几天。这个社区并没有受到政治的干扰。我站在正确位置的唯一迹象是我脚下褪色的粉色门垫。“欢迎来到多尔家，”上面写着。按了一次门铃后，前门开了，一位老妇人走了出来。
"Just cleaning up before Bob gets here," she says. It's Bob Dole's sister, Gloria, and she's as matter-of-fact as Dole himself. She then disappears inside, leaving the door open for me to follow. I do.
“在鲍勃到这儿之前打扫一下，”她说。那是鲍勃·多尔的妹妹格洛丽亚，她和多尔本人一样务实。然后她消失在里面，留着门让我进去。我照做了。
Bob Dole's boyhood home-- his official residence, in fact-- is instantly recognizable to anyone who had grandparents in the 1960s. 1960s old-person's furniture, low-backed lounge chairs; 1960s old-person colors, unnatural shades of green; and 1960s old-person smells, 1940s perfume. Over the roar of the 1960s vacuum cleaner, Gloria opens various drawers and tosses onto various counters items for me to inspect. The drawers contain hundreds of loose photographs of Dole in his youth that neither Gloria nor anyone else has looked at in years. One shot depicts Dole modeling clothes in a fashion show staged by a local department store. Another shows him shirtless, with his muscles slightly flexed. As a collection, they capture both Dole's natural obedience-- he always poses-- and his intense physical vanity. How many 18-year-olds in 1940 lifted weights?
鲍勃·多尔的童年故居——实际上是他的官方住所——对于任何在20世纪60年代有祖父母的人来说都是一眼就能认出来的。60年代老年人的家具，低靠背的躺椅；60年代老年人的色彩，不自然的绿色调；以及60年代老年人的气味，40年代的香水。在60年代吸尘器的轰鸣声中，格洛丽亚打开各种抽屉，把里面的东西扔在各种台面上让我检查。抽屉里有数百张多尔年轻时的照片，格洛丽亚或其他任何人都已经很多年没看过了。一张照片显示多尔在当地一家百货公司举办的时装秀上展示服装。另一张显示他赤裸着上身，肌肉微微隆起。作为一组收藏，它们既捕捉到了多尔天生的服从性——他总是摆姿势——也捕捉到了他强烈的身体虚荣心。1940年有几个18岁的人举重？
"He looks like a movie star," I say to Gloria.
“他看起来像个电影明星，”我对格洛丽亚说。
"He was a movie star," she says quickly. "He is a movie star."
“他就是个电影明星，”她很快说道，“他是一个电影明星。”
The whole thing happened so fast, it seems only natural that I'm ransacking the home of the Republican presidential nominee. After a thorough search of the premises, we move on to the garage, passing, beside Dole's bed, a strange pair of Little Black Sambo rag dolls of the sort they don't even allow in the South anymore. The inside of the garage is a welter of ancient possessions that have long since ceased to serve any useful purpose-- five-pound cameras, medicine balls, that sort of thing.
这一切发生得太快了，我洗劫这位共和党总统提名人的家似乎是很自然的事。在彻底搜查了房舍后，我们移步到车库，经过多尔床边时，看到了一对奇怪的“小黑人桑波”布娃娃，这种东西现在在南方甚至都不允许存在了。车库内部堆满了早已失去任何用途的古老财物——五磅重的摄像机、药球之类东西。
The outside is equally unremarkable, save for the jury-rigged system of sausage-shaped weights that Dole used to rebuild his arm after the war. According to Gloria, the contraption has simply hung there for the past 50 years, untouched by time or fate. Dole just likes having it around.
外面同样平淡无奇，除了多尔战后用来重建手臂的那套临时拼凑的香肠状重物系统。据格洛丽亚说，这个装置在过去50年里一直挂在那里，不受时间和命运的影响。多尔只是喜欢把它留在身边。
As I watch the white rope spool through the eye of the silver pulley, I realize I am also watching Bob Dole's campaign in microcosm. Somewhere in America, Dole is either giving a speech or preparing to give a speech in which he invokes the place where I now stand and the things he once did here.
看着白色的绳子穿过银色滑轮的孔眼，我意识到我也在微观层面上看着鲍勃·多尔的竞选。在美国的某个地方，多尔要么正在发表演讲，要么正准备发表演讲，他在演讲中援引我现在所站的这个地方和他曾经在这里所做的事情。
"Now let's just take Bob Dole," he'll say, typically. "Nothing special about me. Grew up in a small town. Dad wears overalls to work every day for 42 years, was proud of it. Grew up in a basement apartment, six of us, to make ends meet, in Russell, Kansas. Didn't have any money, but we had lots of values." Then he will allude artfully to his war wound and his heroic recovery from it.
“现在我们以鲍勃·多尔为例，”他通常会说，“我没什么特别的。在一个小镇长大。爸爸为了维持生计，每天都穿工装裤工作42年，他对此感到自豪。在堪萨斯州的拉塞尔，住在一个地下室公寓里，我们家有六口人，日子紧巴巴的。虽然没钱，但我们有很多价值观。”然后他会艺术地暗指他的战争伤口以及他从那次伤痛中英雄般的康复。
The insistence on the importance of events that have occurred 50 years ago in a place where he hasn't lived for 35 years is more than a little strange. It's as if Dole has made a bargain with himself, and with those who would judge him, which enables him to cease all serious self-examination after the age of 25. The deal is something like this. Dole agrees to believe that it was worth it to have his arm and his vanity shattered for the sake of his country. In return, the country agrees not to question what lurks inside him. Thanks to a single decision he made 50 years ago, he is forever the war hero. It's a strangely stunted view of 73 years on the planet.
对发生在50年前、位于一个他已经35年没住过的地方的事件重要性的坚持，稍微有点奇怪。这就像多尔与自己、与那些评价他的人达成了一项交易，这使他在25岁之后就停止了所有严肃的自我审视。这笔交易大致是这样的：多尔同意相信，为了他的国家，他即使毁掉自己的手臂和虚荣心也是值得的。作为交换，国家同意不去探究他内心深处隐藏的东西。多亏了他50年前做出的那个单一决定，他永远是战争英雄。这是一个关于在地球上度过73年生活的一个奇怪而发育不良的视角。
Morry Taylor asks me to meet him in the parking lot by the San Diego Convention Center. But the convention center is closed and the police who surround it have no idea where to find the parking lot. After a half-hour search, I ask a cop if he's seen 5,000 people on Harley-Davidson motorcycles-- the number Morry promised to deliver to the Dole campaign. The police officer looks at me as if I am mad.
莫里·泰勒让我去圣地亚哥会展中心旁边的停车场见他。但会展中心关闭了，包围它的警察根本不知道停车场在哪里。经过半小时的搜寻，我问一名警察是否看到过5000人骑着哈雷摩托车——莫里承诺提供给多尔竞选团队的数量。警察看着我，仿佛我疯了。
"How many?" he asks incredulously.
“多少？”他怀疑地问道。
"5,000," I say.
“5000，”我说。
"There is no way you get 5,000 motorcycles anywhere near here," he says. For the first time since I met him seven months ago, I doubt Morry's ability to throw a party. How do you find 5,000 bikers anyway?
“你不可能把5000辆摩托车弄到这里附近的任何地方，”他说。自七个月前认识他以来，我第一次怀疑莫里举办派对的能力。话说回来，你怎么找到5000名摩托车手？
Soon enough, I find the parking lot. It lies directly behind a small cluster of protesters, a half mile or so from the convention center. It consists of maybe four acres of concrete at the back of which is a stage. Over the stage is an American flag. And in front of the flag is a huge banner. It reads, "Titan-- America's Newest Tire Company." That's Morry's company.
很快，我找到了停车场。它位于抗议者小群体后方，距离会展中心大约半英里。它由大约四英亩的混凝土组成，后方是一个舞台。舞台上方是一面美国国旗。旗子前面是一条巨大的横幅。上面写着：“泰坦——美国最新的轮胎公司。”那是莫里的公司。
On the stage are five large black men playing loud instruments, each of whom wears a bandanna that says, "The Grizz." That's Morry.
舞台上有五名身材高大的黑人男子在演奏响亮的乐器，每个人都戴着写有“灰熊”字样的头巾。那就是莫里。
At the front of the stage, with a cigar jutting straight out from his mouth, gyrating slightly to the funk, is Morry.
舞台前方，雪茄直直地从嘴里探出，随着放克音乐微微扭动，是莫里。
The roar of approaching motorcycles soon drowns out everything. Not 5,000, but 7,000 motorcycles are streaming across a bridge. They are ridden by 7,000 Republicans and led by half the United States Congress and various local bigwigs-- Newt Gingrich and Trent Lott, Ben Nighthorse Campbell and Dick Armey. But from the moment the bikers arrive at the gates, the Dole campaign ensures that pretty much everything goes wrong. Dole's promise to attend causes the police to keep 6,800 bikers out on the highway. Letting them in will prove too much of a security risk, they say.
摩托车接近的轰鸣声很快淹没了一切。不是5000辆，而是7000辆摩托车正在穿过一座桥。它们由7000名共和党人驾驶，由半个美国国会和各种地方大人物——纽特·金里奇和特伦特·洛特、本·奈特霍斯·坎贝尔和迪克·阿米带队。但从骑手到达大门的那一刻起，多尔竞选团队确保了几乎每件事都出了差错。多尔出席的承诺导致警察把6800名摩托车手挡在了高速公路上。他们说，让他们进来将被证明是太大的安全风险。
The thick line dutifully comes to a halt. And the bikers wait restlessly. The Dole campaign goes back and forth until everyone involved is thoroughly unhappy. An hour or so later, the Dole campaign finally admits that Dole won't be coming. The effect is immediate. The senators and congressmen vanish. As the politicians exit out the back gate, the 3,000 or so bikers who remain on the highway enter through the front.
那条厚重的队列顺从地停了下来。摩托车手们焦躁不安地等待着。多尔竞选团队来回交涉，直到所有相关人员都彻底不高兴为止。大约一小时后，多尔竞选团队最终承认多尔不会来了。效果立竿见影。参议员和国会议员消失了。当政客们从后门退出时，留在高速公路上的那3000名左右的骑手从前门进入。
Morry claims that most of the bikers are actually doctors and lawyers. But these are doctors and lawyers with wild, big bellies and long facial hair. To a man, they are covered in patches that identify them as ardent champions of the American way. Their most popular cause, by far, is the Vietnam War. Everyone is either a veteran or a friend of a veteran. "Hanoi Jane-- traitor by choice, commie by injection," reads a typical armband.
莫里声称大多数摩托车手实际上是医生和律师。但这可是有着狂野大肚子和长脸部毛发的医生和律师。他们每个人身上都覆盖着标明他们是美国方式的热情拥护者的补丁。他们最受欢迎的事业莫过于越战。每个人要么是退伍军人，要么是退伍军人的朋友。“河内简——选择性的叛徒，注射式的共产党，”一条典型的臂带上写着。
The event quickly degenerates into an enjoyable experience. The glee on Morry's face as the bikers-- he's already calling them "my bikers"-- roar into the lot calls to mind a small child on Christmas morning. The bikers, for their part, seem thrilled, especially when Morry moonwalks across the stage and hurls Grizz T-shirts into the raucous crowd. As he does, the band strikes up a new song, "It's your thing, do what you gotta to. I can't tell you what not to do."
活动很快演变成一种愉快的体验。当骑手们——他已经称他们为“我的骑手”——轰鸣进入停车场时，莫里脸上的喜悦让人想起圣诞节早晨的小孩。摩托车手们似乎也感到非常兴奋，特别是当莫里在舞台上做出太空步并将“灰熊”T恤扔向喧闹的人群时。当他这样做时，乐队奏响了一首新歌，“这是你的事，做你必须做的。我不能告诉你什么不该做。”
Five hours later, I sit behind Ollie North's family watching Pat Buchanan take the stage at a rally in Escondido. Buchanan is going to remain inside the Republican Party. That much we know from the advance copies of the speech distributed by his staff. What we don't know is how his followers will take the news.
五小时后，我坐在奥利·诺斯的家人身后，看着帕特·布坎南在埃斯孔迪多的集会上登上舞台。布坎南将留在共和党内。我们从他的工作人员分发的演讲稿预先副本中了解到了这一点。我们不知道的是，他的追随者会如何接受这个消息。
One moment at the start of the ceremony speaks volumes about what Buchanan's followers are up to, as opposed to what Buchanan claims he's up to. After the Pledge of Allegiance, a claque at the back of the room tacks on a pro-life appendix. "Born and unborn," they shout. When I express astonishment that they have dared to amend the Pledge of Allegiance, a fellow journalist gives me a where-have-you-been look and explains that they've also rewritten "The Star-Spangled Banner" to incorporate some pro-life language.
仪式开始时的一个时刻深刻地说明了布坎南的追随者们在做什么，而不是布坎南声称他自己在做什么。在效忠誓词之后，房间后方的一群人在后面加了一个反堕胎的附录。“生下来的和没生下来的，”他们高喊道。当我表达对他们竟敢修改效忠誓词的震惊时，一位同行记者给了我一个“你一直在哪儿”的眼神，并解释说他们还重写了《星条旗》，加入了一些反堕胎的语言。
Nothing illustrates so well how anti-conservative Buchanan's movement truly is. Its goal is not to conserve the past but to advance a radical agenda. The constant invocation of the past-- the founding fathers, the declaration, et cetera, is more of a smokescreen than anything else. Given this, it will be difficult to yoke these people to an old-fashioned conservative cause like the Dole campaign. It's like trying to transform a lightning bolt into usable current. That's Dole's real problem here. Temperamentally, he's a conservative. Every fiber in his body is intent on denying anything radical from ever again changing his life.
没有什么比这更能说明布坎南的运动是多么反保守了。其目标不是保守过去，而是推进激进议程。对过去的不断援引——国父、宣言等等——与其说是别的什么，不如说是一个烟幕弹。鉴于此，将这些人与像多尔竞选团队这样的老式保守事业拴在一起将是困难的。这就像试图把一道闪电转化为可用的电流。这就是多尔在这里面临的真正问题。从气质上讲，他是一个保守派。他身体里的每一根纤维都意在否认任何激进的东西再次改变他的生活。
By late afternoon I finally find Morry again, wandering the convention floor. He looks surprised whenever anyone recognizes him. One Fox television crew even stopped to interview him.
到了傍晚，我终于再次找到了莫里，他正在党代会大厅里游荡。每当有人认出他时，他看起来都很惊讶。甚至有一个福克斯电视台的工作人员停下来采访他。
"Mr. Taylor," began the reporter.
“泰勒先生，”记者开口道。
"What do you mean with this 'Mr. Taylor' [BEEP]?" asked Morry.
“你那个‘泰勒先生’是什么意思 [消音]？”莫里问道。
"Morry?" said the reporter uncertainly.
“莫里？”记者不确定地说道。
"The Grizz," boomed Morry.
“灰熊，”莫里大声说道。
I tell him that just a few hours earlier, a man named Ed Harrison took the podium and started his speech with the immortal words, "Now, I'm not a politician and I'm not a lawyer. I'm a businessman." He had stolen Morry's precise words. This, too, Morry can't quite believe. He hasn't entirely grasped the power of the modern media.
我告诉他，就在几小时前，一个叫埃德·哈里森的人走上讲台，以不朽的话语开始了他的演讲：“现在，我不是政客，也不是律师。我是个商人。”他窃取了莫里的原话。对此，莫里也难以置信。他还没有完全掌握现代媒体的力量。
I have decided it's finally time to leave him, and I'm wondering how to break the news. The Taylor campaign has come to an end, at least for the moment. I have forgotten the general rule of American politics-- if you hang with Morry Taylor, the action will follow. The rule continues to obtain. We're sitting in the section reserved for the primary candidates, when Pat Buchanan appears for the first time on the convention floor. He's already got maybe 50 journalists with him. He quickly accumulates another 100, plus several hundred delegates keen to shake his hand.
我决定终于到了离开他的时候了，我想知道该如何打破这个消息。泰勒的竞选活动已经结束了，至少目前是这样。我忘记了美国政治的一般规则——如果你和莫里·泰勒混在一起，行动就会随之而来。规则继续生效。我们坐在预留给初选候选人的区域，帕特·布坎南第一次出现在党代会大厅。他已经有大约50名记者跟随他了。他迅速又积累了100人，再加上几百名渴望与他握手的代表。
The result is a human tsunami that breaks across about a third of the conventional hall and lays waste to anything in its path. "People are being trampled," an enormous security guard shouts into his wrist mic. "Send me 50 people."
结果是一场人肉海啸，冲破了大约三分之一的会展大厅，摧毁了挡在它前面的任何东西。“人们正在被践踏，”一名巨大的保安对着他的手腕麦克风喊道，“给我派50个人来。”
The crowd at the convention has its own logic, however. People merely attract more people. For every added security man, three curiosity seekers join in. So as Buchanan circles the hall, the tension rises. He's like a ball bearing in a roulette wheel trying to decide where to settle. At length, he comes to rest in the seat directly behind Morry. Fully one third of the convention is watching him and ignoring George W. Bush, who is speaking piously from the podium.
然而，党代会上的人群有自己的逻辑。人们只会吸引更多的人。每增加一名保安，就有三名好奇者加入。所以当布坎南绕着大厅转时，紧张局势升级。他就像轮盘赌中的一个滚珠，试图决定在哪里停下。终于，他停在莫里身后的座位上。足足三分之一的党代会都在看着他，而忽略了正在讲台上虔诚地演讲的乔治·W·布什。
"Open up a child daycare center at your church or synagogue." That sort of thing.
“在你的教堂或犹太会堂开设一家儿童日托中心。”之类的话。
"I need more help here," blares the guard into his wrist. "Send help. Send help."
“我这儿需要更多帮助，”保安对着他的手腕大喊，“派人来。派人来。”
Then Buchanan notices Morry. "Morry Taylor is the problem here," he shouts mockingly. "He's ruined the convention."
然后布坎南注意到了莫里。“莫里·泰勒是这里的问题，”他嘲讽地大喊，“他毁了这次党代会。”
"Did they do this to you when you got here, Morry?" shouts Bay Buchanan, joining her brother and ganging up on Morry. It seems needlessly cruel. Morry stands alone watching.
“当你到这里时，他们也这么对你吗，莫里？”贝·布坎南加入她哥哥的行列，联手对付莫里，大声喊道。这似乎是不必要的残酷。莫里独自站着观看。
"It's you, Pat," says Morry. "Leave Shelley with me and take these people out in the street."
“是你，帕特，”莫里说，“把谢莉留给我，带这些人去街上。”
The two former rivals vie to condescend to one another. Buchanan is winning on points until he pushes it one inch too far.
这两位前对手竞相以俯视的态度对待对方。布坎南在点数上领先，直到他做得太过分了一英寸。
"Where's the keg, Morry?" he shouts. "Go get the keg."
“桶在哪儿，莫里？”他大喊，“去拿桶。”
Morry looks up, licks his lip and says, "Hey, Pat, you're unemployed now." Then he turns to the cameras. "He needs a job," Morry explains to the world's news media. "Or else he'll have to take unemployment."
莫里抬起头，舔了舔嘴唇说：“嘿，帕特，你现在失业了。”然后他转向摄像机。“他需要一份工作，”莫里向世界新闻媒体解释说，“否则他就得接受失业了。”
Gerald Ford and George Bush speak. But no one around Buchanan listens. All eyes focus on the troublemaker who is giving serial interviews to the networks. At last, Nancy Reagan appears to eulogize Ronny, which is strange. Republicans behave as if he has already died, whereas Nixon, who has actually died, is treated as if he were still alive. She is followed by Colin Powell.
杰拉德·福特和乔治·布什发表了演讲。但布坎南周围没有人听。所有的目光都集中在那个正连续接受各电视网采访的捣乱分子身上。终于，南希·里根出现悼念罗尼，这很奇怪。共和党人的行为就好像他已经去世了，而尼克松虽然真的去世了，却被对待得像他还活着一样。紧随其后的是科林·鲍威尔。
Then comes what I am sure will be the defining moment of the convention. Powell raises his voice above the crowd and proclaims his belief in abortion rights. The convention rises to its feet to applaud. I turn around and meet Buchanan's gaze.
接着是我想肯定会成为党代会决定性时刻的到来。鲍威尔在大众之上提高了声音，宣称他相信堕胎权。代表大会起立鼓掌。我转过身，迎上布坎南的目光。
"Any reaction?" I ask idiotically. In these circumstances it is, as a rule, impossible to think of a decent question.
“有什么反应吗？”我愚蠢地问道。在这些情况下，通常是不可能想出一个像样的问题的。
"What?" he says.
“什么？”他说。
"Any reaction?" I shout. But the noise from the crowd is too loud.
“有什么反应吗？”我大喊。但来自人群的噪音太大了。
Just in front of Morry, oddly enough, there is a man dressed in a monk's robe. On the back of the robe is a sign. It reads, "Diogenes went through the streets carrying a lantern. He held it up to strangers and said he was looking for an honest man."
奇怪的是，就在莫里前面，有一个穿着僧袍的人。长袍背后有一个牌子。上面写着：“第欧根尼提着灯笼走在街上。他把灯举向陌生人，说他在寻找一个诚实的人。”
Dole has invited Morry to join him on the stage Thursday night. But Morry has, for the second time in as many days, declined Dole's invitation. He figures it will merely be another meaningless free-for-all with everyone who ever thought of running for office crammed on to the stage. Although Morry's aides plead with me to try to change his mind, I can't honestly tell him he's wrong. It's nothing personal, though he's still irritated that Dole lacked the sense to address 7,000 raving loyalists on motorcycles. It's just that convention life is less than it's cracked up to be, he's decided. In the morning his plane will take him and his friends to Las Vegas.
多尔邀请莫里在周四晚上和他一起上台。但莫里在两天内第二次拒绝了多尔的邀请。他觉得这只不过是另一场毫无意义的自由混战，每个曾经想过竞选公职的人都会挤在舞台上。虽然莫里的助手乞求我试着改变他的想法，但我不能诚实地告诉他他是错的。这没什么私人恩怨，尽管他仍然因为多尔缺乏解决7000名骑摩托车的狂热忠诚者的意识而恼火。他只是觉得党代会生活远没有人们吹嘘的那么美好。早晨，他的飞机将带他和他的朋友们去拉斯维加斯。
Michael Lewis-- his campaign diaries appear in The New Republic. This will be in this week's issue.
迈克尔·刘易斯——他的竞选日记出现在《新共和》杂志上。这将出现在本周的期刊中。
Act Four, Party in the Killing Fields. Political conventions, of course, are basically big, glorified TV shows. But they're also the stuff of memory. Photo-snapping and autograph-seeking was everywhere in San Diego. Well, Cassandra Smith's father and grandfather were both Republicans, black Republicans, because of the ethic of self-reliance and because of Abraham Lincoln. And they were trying to change the Republican Party from the inside. And she has this memory of one convention.
第四幕，杀戮场上的派对。当然，政治党代会本质上是大型的、美化的电视节目。但它们也是记忆的产物。在圣地亚哥，到处都是拍照和索要签名的人。嗯，卡桑德拉·史密斯的父亲和祖父都是共和党人，黑人共和党人，因为自力更生的道德观和亚伯拉罕·林肯的缘故。他们试图从内部改变共和党。她对一次代表大会有这样的记忆。
I can't swear that I was the only 10-year-old Negro girl at the 1960 Republican Convention. But with the scarcity of black Republicans, especially as enthusiastic as my father, I think I can make the claim.
我不敢保证我是1960年共和党党代会上唯一的10岁黑人女孩。但考虑到黑人共和党人的稀缺，尤其是像我父亲那样热情的，我想我可以这么说。
"You'll see democracy in action," Daddy promised. "Yes, history in the making. You'll be the only kid in school to see Dick Nixon in person."
“你会看到民主在行动，”爸爸承诺道，“是的，历史正在创造中。你将是学校里唯一看到迪克·尼克松本人的孩子。”
I wasn't impressed. I had just seen Soupy Sales at the state fair. And Nixon was only a vice president. Besides, I'd seen his face every morning when I came downstairs for breakfast. Above the fireplace, in a kind of Republican shrine, surrounded by a grey china elephant and a stack of "I Like Ike" buttons, hung a photo of my father, John Smith, and Richard Nixon shaking hands. It was taken in 1958 when Nixon was vice president and Daddy was one of nine Young Republican Vice Chairmen.
我没被打动。我刚在州博览会上看过苏皮·塞勒斯的表演。而且尼克松只是个副总统。再说，我每天早上下来吃早餐时都能看到他的脸。在壁炉上方，在一个某种共和党神龛里，周围环绕着一只灰色瓷大象和一堆“我喜欢艾克”的徽章，挂着一张我父亲约翰·史密斯和理查德·尼克松握手的照片。那是1958年拍摄的，当时尼克松是副总统，爸爸是九名青年共和党副主席之一。
They are standing toe to toe, wingtip to wingtip, their hands clasped in a no-nonsense handshake. They even look a little alike, same height and build, the same oversize square head, shiny gray suit, intent, unwavering stare. I understand now that these photos were staged for the party faithful. But in 1960, I thought that Dick Nixon and my father were best friends, blood brothers who had cut their palms and clasped them together in a sacred ceremony preserved on film.
他们脚尖对脚尖，鞋尖对鞋尖站着，手紧紧地握在一起，做出那种不折不扣的握手姿势。他们甚至看起来有点像，身高和体格相同，同样超大号的方头，闪亮的灰西装，专注、坚定的凝视。我现在明白这些照片是为党内忠诚者摆拍的。但在1960年，我以为迪克·尼克松和我父亲是最好的朋友，是血盟兄弟，他们在胶卷上留下的神圣仪式中割破手掌并紧握在一起。
Daddy was proud of that photo-- framed it, bragged on it, and made sure his daughters kept it dusted. As far as he was concerned, he and Dick were comrades from the front lines. His old friend was about to be promoted from vice president to president. And we were traveling to Chicago to cheer him on.
爸爸为那张照片感到自豪——装裱起来，到处吹嘘，并确保他的女儿们把它擦拭干净。对他而言，他和迪克是来自前线的战友。他的老朋友即将从副总统升为总统。我们正前往芝加哥为他加油。
We'd been in Chicago a couple of days, and Mother and I still couldn't get into the convention. Every morning, Daddy had left us waiting while he searched for spectator tickets. When we finally got inside, the seats were in the nosebleed section. I was troubled. If Nixon and my daddy are such good friends, why are we sitting up here?
我们在芝加哥待了几天，妈妈和我仍然进不去党代会。每天早上，爸爸都把我们晾在一边，自己去寻找观众票。当我们最终进去时，座位在最顶层。我很困扰。如果尼克松和我爸爸是那么好的朋友，我们为什么要坐在那儿？
The next day we were in luck. The Republican women had planned to wear yellow dresses to a demonstration. Mother wore hers and we slipped onto the convention floor. What can I tell you about a convention from the eyes of a 10-year-old? Mostly, I saw belt buckles, breasts, and bellies. Red, white, and blue balloons, the crush of bodies, funny hats, popcorn, the smell of Old Spice and Aqua Velva, grown-ups shouting and pushing like a bunch of kids, crushed toes, Texans in 10-gallon hats, and Goldwater delegates who never gave up trying to make you wear their buttons.
第二天我们走运了。共和党女性计划穿着黄色的裙子参加示威。妈妈穿上了她的，我们溜进了会场。关于一次代表大会，我可以从一个10岁孩子的眼里告诉你什么？大部分时间，我看到了皮带扣、胸部和肚皮。红白蓝三色的气球、拥挤的人群、滑稽的帽子、爆米花、古龙水和须后水的味道，大人们像一群孩子一样尖叫和推搡、踩伤的脚趾、戴着宽边帽的德克萨斯人，以及从不放弃试图让你佩戴他们徽章的戈德沃特代表。
We joined the parade of Republican women marching round and round the floor demonstrating for or against something. Somehow we were spotted as frauds and led through the exit doors and into the midday sun.
我们加入了共和党女性的游行队伍，在会场周围一圈又一圈地走动，示威支持或反对某事。不知何故，我们被认作是骗子，被带出会场门，进入了午后的阳光下。
The international amphitheater was in the middle of the stockyards. And although most of the slaughterhouses had closed, the smell of death was everywhere. Nearby, Darling and Company, the last of the rendering firms, was boiling down hides, hooves, heads, tails into glue. When the wind was right, you could smell it as far as Hyde Park, four miles away. But on a windless August day, we couldn't breathe. We covered our eyes and mouths. We begged the guards to let us back in or send a message to father. We were stranded alone in a vacant lot overgrown by weeds.
国际圆形剧场位于牲畜饲养场中间。尽管大多数屠宰场已经关闭，但死亡的气味无处不在。附近，最后一家炼油厂达林公司正在把兽皮、蹄子、头颅、尾巴煮成胶水。当风向合适时，你在四英里外的海德公园都能闻到它。但在一个无风的八月天，我们无法呼吸。我们捂住眼睛和嘴巴。我们求警卫让我们回去，或者帮我们给父亲传个信。我们被困在一个杂草丛生的空地上。
By now, I'd had it with Dick Nixon and decided the photo was a fraud, the convention nothing but a staged circus. We had been abandoned, locked out. I still haven't found a political home. This year, the Republican talk about inclusion makes me nervous. They repeat it too often and with too little evidence. But this week, for the first time since 1960, I had a calm political discussion with my father. I was surprised. Although he's proud of Colin Powell and still likes Republican economics, he feels as left out as I do.
到现在，我对迪克·尼克松受够了，决定那张照片是个骗局，党代会不过是一场摆拍的马戏团。我们被抛弃、锁在门外了。我至今还没有找到一个政治归宿。今年，共和党关于包容性的谈话让我感到紧张。他们重复得太频繁，证据又太少。但本周，自1960年以来，我第一次和父亲进行了平静的政治讨论。我很惊讶。尽管他为科林·鲍威尔感到骄傲，仍然喜欢共和党的经济学，但他感到和我一样被排斥。
"The party hasn't changed," he admitted. "They don't want us. Not unless you do what they tell you. That's my problem. I never did what they told me." And for the first time, he explained to me the reason we didn't get tickets to the convention floor in 1960. The state party leaders wanted him to run for the one office usually reserved for blacks. Instead, he ran for a mainstream position and won. And that's how we ended up in a vacant lot that smelled of death, pounding on the doors to get in.
“这个党没变，”他承认，“他们不想要我们。除非你按他们说的做。这就是我的问题。我从来没按他们说的做过。”这是他第一次向我解释我们1960年没有得到会场票的原因。州党领导人希望他竞选那个通常留给黑人的职位。相反，他竞选了一个主流职位并获胜了。这就是我们最终落在一个充满死亡气息的空地，在门上猛拍以求进入的原因。
Chicago writer Cassandra Smith. She's got a story in the new book, TriQuarterly New Writers. Music by the late Oscar Brown III.
芝加哥作家卡桑德拉·史密斯。她在新书《TriQuarterly新作家》中有一个故事。音乐由已故的奥斯卡·布朗三世创作。
Well, our program was produced today by Peter Clowney and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Hey, want to hear an outtake? Sure you do. From our recording session with Michael Lewis when he did his campaign diaries. Hold on, let me this cued up. Here we go.
好了，我们的节目今天由彼得·克劳尼和我制作，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。嘿，想听听花絮吗？当然想。来自我们与迈克尔·刘易斯录制他的竞选日记时的录音。等一下，让我把它调出来。开始吧。
As he does, the band strikes up a new song. Now, what do I do with this? I don't know what to do with it. [SINGING[ It's your thing-- I can't do that.
当他这样做时，乐队奏响了一首新歌。现在，我该拿这个怎么办？我不知道该怎么处理它。[唱歌] 这是你的事——我不能那样做。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
As he does, the band-- I can't do this.
当他这样做时，乐队——我做不到。
If you would like a copy of this program-- it's only $10-- call us at WBEZ in Chicago. 312-832-3380. Our email address is [email protected] .
如果您想要此节目的副本——只需10美元——请致电芝加哥的WBEZ。312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是 [email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
[SINGING] It's your thing. I can't do that. You ruined my life.
[唱歌] 这是你的事。我做不到。你毁了我的生活。
Yeah, are we ruining yours? Are we? Well, either way, we're going to be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
是的，我们在毁掉你的吗？是我们吗？好吧，无论如何，我们下周将回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。